c'est nécessaire d'avoir la sécurité et
la protection de nos droits et nos
libertés
nous faisons les deux et c'est important
les deux les deux se renforce et dans
nos projets de loi rendant plus de
ressources et de pouvoir non mots pour
des agences de sécurité de police
maintenant il ya une vraie menace dans
le monde
le terrorisme djihadiste international
on doit ces conséquences
on doit être contre ça et dont on doit
protéger une rue limitée ce que nous ont
fait mal mais c'est clair que c'est lé
plus dangereuse loi dans l'histoire du
canada cette voix ronde les canadiens -
libre et en même temps rendre le canada
noir sécuritaire c'est clair que cette
loi
je vous demande est déposée c'est clair
que cette loi est vraiment dangereuse et
c'est comme nous avions augmenté les
risques de collision sont mettre en
place un système de feux de
signalisation d'un mètre d'eau
monsieur monsieur harper pense qu'on n'a
pas besoin de rien faire de plus pour
protéger nos libertés
monsieur mulcair pense qu'on ne doivent
rien faire de plus pour protéger notre
sécurité
le parti libéral veut faire les deux en
même temps c'est pour ça nous proposons
un comité de parlementaires pour
surveiller toutes nos institutions de
police et de sécurité nationale c'est
cet équilibre là que le parti libéral a
toujours su faire et qui va continuer le
faire mais je dis c'est cette loi ne
respecte pas le nécessaire équilibre
entre liberté et sécurité c'est ce qu'il
faut faire dans la société sinon on fait
le jeu des fanatiques
cela étant dit il aurait fallu renforcer
les pouvoirs du comité de surveillance
du service de renseignement canadiens
est sûre ça je rappelle que les
conservateurs le npd et les libéraux ont
tous appuyé la nomination d' arthur
porter au comité de surveillance des
services de renseignements du canada or
je me tiens si ce monsieur qui se
répondent
monsieur mulcair je suis d'accord avec
madame mais cette loi constitue une
attaque en règle contre les droits et
libertés de l'ensemble des canadiens
quand nous on a commencé avec notre
position il y avait plus de 80 % des
canadiens qui étaient en faveur de la
loi mais sur une question de principe on
s'est tenu debout tout comme le npd
était le seul à se tenir debout contre
la loi sur les mesures de guerre depuis
autre dossier a mis les centaines de
québécois en prison sans procès on va
abroger purement et simplement la loi